I want to write this expression here as
a decimal the first question that might
pop in your head is do I multiply four
times 1,000 then add three then multiply
a thousand then add 67 then multiply by
one over a thousand or do I do the
multiplication first to answer that
question we just have to remind
ourselves about order of operations
order of operations if you have a bunch
of multiplication in addition in a row
like this you will do the multiplication
first so you will do the multiplication
first let me put some parentheses here
to remind us of that so let's figure out
what each of these expressions in the
parentheses actually represent what's 4
times 1 million well that's 4 million
what's 3 times 1,000
well that's 3,000 3,000 what is 67 times
1,000 there's a bunch of ways of
thinking about this actually let me let
me write them all over here well I'll do
it I'll do the the most obvious one
right over here 67 times 1,000 is 67 67
thousandths and we can represent this
literally as 67 thousand or we could
represent this as 60 over a thousand
plus seven over one thousand and what's
60 over a thousand well 60 over a
thousand is six hundredths 600 so let me
put that in a different color six
hundredths seven thousand so you could
view this as 67 thousand or you could
view this as six hundredths and 7
thousandths either way let's add all of
these things together so we have four
million so the four in the millions
place literally represents four million
then we have no hundred thousands we
have no ten thousands but then we have
three thousands so the three is in the
thousands place let me put a comma here
so we could keep track of things and
then we have no hundreds we have no tens
we have no ones we don't even have any
tenths but we do have some hundredths we
have six
it's we have six hundredths and then we
have some thousands we have seven
thousands so we put that seven in the
thousands in the thousands place so we
could read this as 4 million 3607
thousandths or we could read it as 4
million 3067 thousandth 67 thousandths